This video is sponsored by movement,
watches in sunglasses,
more on movement at the end of this
video.
Hey,
wise crack,
jared here,
we all just saw thor ragnarok and
surprise.
We have some thoughts.
Not only is it quite possibly the
funniest smart movie,
it's also very close to being the
smartest.
Like most marvel clicks,
there's a metric buttload of smashy
fight,
punctuated by smug.
Self awareness is a friend from work,
but underneath the ocean of jokes,
fights and uncredited Matt Damon Cameos.
There are a few scenes that speak to
really interesting ideas,
but before we dive in any further,
here's your obligatory spoiler warning.
One of the most enduring images of the
movie is thor missing,
and I just like his father odin and we
couldn't help but ponder.
If in norse mythology,
odin loses his eye to see a greater
knowledge.
What truth does thor see when he loses
his eye?
So let's see why marvel took thor's.
I in this quick take on Thor Ragnarok.
First,
a quick recap for returns to as garden
from a spirit quest complete with the
crown of a fire.
Giant only defined Loki in charge
disguised as Odin.
They go to find the real odin who
promptly dies immediately after big
sister Hela Goddess of death comes back
from her banishment to hot topic to
claim the as guardian thrown and expand
the empire.
So she destroys thor's hammer and sends
thor and Loki tumbling in the space.
Thor ends up being a gladiator on a
planet called Secar.
Loki weasels himself into Jeff Gold
boons aristocracy.
And with the help of new friends like
Valkyrie and his colleague,
the incredible hulk,
thor gets back to asgard by Tele and
saves his people.
What a ride.
So sure.
Door fights the hulk again.
Jeff Goldwin plays a space.
Cj and Loki gets rescued by Acuvi rock
monster.
But what's more interesting is rackner
entrepreneur occupation with the past
and how it forms the world we live in.
This is most clearly seen during hellos
reign over as guard.
When hello arrives,
She sees a fresco depicting as guards
history as all peace treaties and
celebrations.
But that's not how she remembers it to
her as guards.
History is all blood and conquest and
feeding enemies.
Tour giant Wolf.
She wrecks the fresco revealing one
hidden beneath one that depicts the
history.
Odin tried to sweep under the rug.
He anhelica conquering,
killing,
and generally wreaking havoc.
She destroys what appears to be the
entire as guardian army on her own.
Then brings her old army's back to life
and suddenly as guard is just like when
she left it,
a military dictatorship run by a power
hungry deity.
What's really clever here is that just
as hello wants to reach into the dark
and bring the past back to life,
so to do all our central characters need
to reconcile with their past in order to
make any progress.
This is the substance buried under all
the comedy in this movie.
It's interested in how we deal with our
past.
For the whole,
this is simple.
Banner has been stuck in hoke mode for
two years.
It's not until he witnesses his past by
seeing a video of black widow that he's
forced to confront what he left behind
when he flew into outer space,
allowing banner to emerge and the escape
to truly start.
Valkyrie used to be a member of an
elite,
all female as guardians,
strikeforce,
but ages ago when Hella killed everyone
but her and a huge battle she gave up
that life and became a scavenger.
It's only when she confronts those
memories that she can return to the
heroism she left behind.
Lokeys confrontation with the past comes
through his connection to his brother.
Loki has always wanted thor to recognize
him either with love or fear,
but toward the end of the movie,
Dor indicates that he no longer cares
about Loki.
It takes until the last 20 minutes of
the movie,
but Loki finally realizes that to start
his own future,
he has to grow out of the person he was
in the past.
Despite his self aggrandizing battle cry
of your savior is here.
We see real growth in his decision not
to steal the tesseract and in the fact
that after the fight he sticks around
instead of running away.
But what about thor?
Well,
that's the biggest issue with this idea
of history and what keeps the film from
being decisively Marvel's smartest
movie.
We never get to see thor dealing with
his own history,
nor with as guards.
The closest we get to this is his battle
with hello,
which could be considered as a
metaphorical conflict between as God's
future and it's past.
This is the concept of the heart of full
ragnar rock.
In order to move into the future,
people and societies need to reckon with
their past and idea that is very present
throughout human history.
It starts with the way that society's
tell stories to themselves about
themselves for a long time,
as God presented itself as a warlike
culture.
When Odin one of the shift toward a more
peaceful arrangement,
he rewrote the history of as guard to
exclude Hela and all the fighting and
position himself as a benevolent
protector.
You've probably heard the phrase that
history is written by the winners,
but according to scholars like Michelle
from co and Jenny Ed Kins history is
written for the winners,
but what that means is that history is
written to justify past violence and set
the stage for whatever needs to happen
in the future.
Atkins explains this process by
describing the end of a war.
Victory Parades,
remembrance ceremonies and war museums
tell of glory,
courage and sacrifice.
The Nation is renewed.
The state strengthened with the
commemoration of the past.
We justify the measures taken to reach
the future.
That means the story of the past
dictates the future.
We see this idea played with at the
beginning when lokeys disguises Odin,
he's putting on a play recontextualizing
his deception as sacrifice and rewriting
the history of as guard with himself as
a hero,
all wild munching on fresh grapes.
The as guard around him is centered on
indulgence and celebration and Loki
crafts its history to justify that
behavior.
He's not the only one to pull this trick
and he's certainly not the most
dangerous for Hela as guards.
History is inextricably tied to this
idea of place.
She believes that expanding the
territory of as guard is the same as
making as guard.
More powerful.
This equation of a people to a place has
a long role in human history.
Theorist David Campbell explains the
dangers of time,
political identity,
and security to a single place.
One of his ideas is essentially that
when a population and its power is tied
to a place that makes everyone outside
of that place and enemy and a potential
threat and in a world full of potential
threats,
safety is an illusion and that means
hell is wars would wage forever.
It takes a visit from ghost dad for thor
to understand that the people of Asgard
matter more than the place or even the
name.
This is the epiphany that lead owed into
casting hell out her militarism based on
defending the land of as guard from
threats or expanding its power would be
the ruin of the people of Asgard.
This is why thor loses his eye in norse
mythology.
Odin trades his iphone knowledge.
Similarly,
thor loses his eye in the moment when he
finally sees the truth that what really
matters isn't territory.
It's the people who create the culture.
In the end,
Loki unleashes the fire giant who
destroys as guard and hello whippet by
destroying the territory and making the
as guardians,
nomadic space travelers.
They now have a chance to create their
own history unbound from the past
despite the pain it brings underneath a
secar sized pile of space,
junk,
special effects and fantastic jokes.
Ragnarok is a movie about how we
understand national social and personal
identity in the context of our past,
whether for better or worse those paths
and form our futures and only by
confronting them directly can we ever
really move on.
Hope you guys enjoyed the movie.
Thanks for watching peace.
Now y'all probably noticed the,
we're looking pretty fly with this sexy
new haircut.
Well if you've decided it's time to step
up your style game too.
Why not grab a new watch or pair of
sunglasses from moving.
If you're one of the first 200 wise
crack fans to make a purchase at
mvmt.com/wise
crack using the offer code wisecrack
you'll get $15 off your purchase.
Founded on the idea that good style
shouldn't break the bank movement cuts
out the middleman giving you designer
great apparel at low prices would their
classic minimalist designs and Quality
Construction Movement watches keep you
on time and in style.
All starting at 95 bucks and the
sunglasses are just cool.
They're lightweight,
handmade and start at 70 bucks with the
option to polarize most pairs.
So head over to mvmt.com/wise
crack or click the link in the
description.
Be sure to use the discount code wise
crack to get $15 off your purchase.
Free Shipping and returns are included.
So join the movement.
Thanks to Movement for sponsoring this
video and we've got more great stuff on
the way for y'all,
including videos on the Emoji movie,
the prestige and tons more.
So if you haven't already,
don't forget to subscribe and ring that
bell.
Catch y'all next time.
Peace.